[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to a
special
america edition of honest trailer
commentaries
america they're all special america
editions
that's true everything is a special
american edition
uh my favorite american's with milan
harris how's it going man hey what's
going on i have a favorite wow
what am i impressed you're on the mount
rushmore for sure that's awesome um
so today uh is is election day go vote
if you haven't then come back to this
show as a little treat
um because after that we're going to be
talking about the national treasure
movie uh just the first one we didn't do
the sequel
uh we'll be watching just a choice on
your part by the way i assumed when you
said watch national treasure we would be
doing book of secrets in there
i just want to leave open the
possibility of revisiting this world
in two to four years there's so much
there's so much to unpack
lon you might not have noticed that they
stopped making new movies so every
honest trailer we make is one less on
this trailer we'll get to make
yeah um that said uh today we we will be
watching uh national treasure one
talking about it giving you our behind
the scenes thoughts watching some
deleted scenes
uh responding to comments from viewers
like you if you're in the live chat
right now
maybe over this trip nope that direction
uh uh put your question in and we'll
answer it at the end of the show
and then tease you with next week's on
his trailer sounds good great love it
um national treasure man these movies
are
they're they're definitely stupid um but
i think that they
are they're light and breezy and not
like in a self-serious way
where you really groan about it like
these are social studies
uh classroom movies to me yes
i mean you you would think that for the
people who are alive and creating these
puzzles or the historians that are
solving them
you could make the challenges a little
bit more elaborate than like the liberty
bell
and valley forge like they're going over
literally the stuff we learn about in
like junior high
like if you take like any ap us history
student could be like
what about the whiskey rebellion and the
rough riders like there are more
esoteric
references they could be coming up with
here uh
and they're just going for like the the
easy single
every time well the founding fathers
in their infinite wisdom also i guess
they knew everything that was going to
remain important to future generations
right ben franklin these glasses i wear
these are going to be iconic
they're all going to remember my
stovetop inventions
so uh yeah no it is it's a little silly
but what i was going to say is
i feel like if they had gone with the
tone of like the da vinci code movies
it wouldn't work no it's just that they
go for the kind of
goofy adventure throwback tone
that makes it almost a comedy that's
like okay i'm into this it's funny
although it was missing like the da
vinci code had the like
uh slightly mutated opus dei
bald killing guy i think that i think
that this movie could have used
some type of igor you know stalking uh
stalking ourselves
right rather than like sean bean who's
just like you know
european mercenary number four
a more colorful nemesis yeah
yeah um why not like a monster guarding
the treasure room as long as you're
going freemason's illuminati
buried crypts under churches like
why not uh why not a troll down there
well i think we have
a real lack of mythology in america i
mean we do this is it
like it's it's the founding fathers um
that's about as deep as it goes and then
everything else is like too contemporary
like you're not going to bury like jfk
in a tomb with like a
a syringe full of syphilis chasing you
around like
bigfoot throw big foot down there that's
a native
uh that's that's an american myth right
i would love to watch nick cage fight
bigfoot and he probably does in one of
his direct-to-dvd movies i bet if that
hasn't been made that 2022 will be
getting nick cage versus bigfoot in some
contests
yeah um i guess what else is there to
say i mean it's
like the guy's background uh i think the
guy who made it
uh turtle top is a guy who made three
ninjas and
was it cool runnings or something movies
like that where their phenomenon with
the travolta
yeah he gets like a magic brain tumor
that makes him smart
sorry sorry i missed that one that's
what that move spoiler alert uh if
he gets super smart and then the whole
movie you're like what made him super
smart and then you find out he's like
he's dying of brain cancer and it like
stimulated the parts of his brain right
bittersweet folks
give me all the oscars um wow
the the john travolta wants an oscar
movie category
is very deep and bizarre um yeah uh
what's the one where he plays an angel
and like eats all the sugar
uh michael michael yes yeah
also you know what turtletop did most
recently uh a little film called the meg
oh you're right he did through the meg
yeah a great idea
wow good for him so uh nicki cage
stealing the declaration of independence
to jason statham almost punching a giant
shark it leads
so close naturally into the other meg
too he's got to punch that shark
um yeah come on what do they think now i
haven't
uh seen the sequel to this uh to this
film oh do you can you give me like a
rough sense of
where it goes from here does it get up
more over the top does it kind of stay
in the same lane
it's very much like more of the oh
you'd like to see more of this then yeah
let's uh
except it's like uh civil war era
so rather than american revolution
founding father stuff
they're hunting for like stuff from the
19th century but other than that i don't
really
remember that i do wish that they
treated this
that they kept making him and this was
kind of like you know the x-men
franchise that keeps doing like decade
hops and stuff like that until he was
going through uh you know reagan's tomb
and like finding the
secret in his jelly beans and stuff like
that right i'm looking it's uh another
gates ancestor is now suspected of being
involved with the lincoln assassination
so he needs to
find john wilkes booth's diary to prove
his
own family's innocence innocence that's
the setup of a national treasure
because are they like gonna put them in
jail for killing abraham no it's to
clear
the gates family name spencer it's
important they're not gonna put nicholas
how dare you
kill lincoln sir i mean i i what
i think you have to respect about that
is it came out after that simpsons
episode where
homer's looking for lincoln's gold but
it's okay the same
premise perfect to come in after the
simpsons did it just be like yeah
lincoln's gold again
screw you i love it all right well
simpsons did it
um and we did national treasure so let's
watch
our honest trailer for national treasure
together
as a nation go vote
everybody then come back
i'm not going to tell you if you love
historical mysteries
switch the settings to easy mode or a
scavenger hunt that anyone could figure
out
even kids and americans
national treasure when the declaration
of
independence is in danger someone's
going to steal the declaration of
independence
one group will steal the declaration of
i'm gonna steal the declaration of
independence so that no one else can
steal
the declaration of independence i'm not
gonna let you steal the declaration of
independence
then use it to resteal above um
we kind of undersold how many times they
talk about stealing the declaration of
independence because it was
the first half of the film if you track
and i know this because i did if you
track every time they say the phrase
declaration of independence it's like a
really surprisingly long list
the the amount of times they say you
think they'd start shortening it to the
declaration
or the deck the deck the di take your
pick historians
who deal with it every day like if you
work at the national archives
as diane krueger does in this film you
must have a shorthand that you use
you're not saying the declaration yeah
it's like potus you know everything
right yeah or like our exhibit
18 you know like they've got their
inside or whatever they call it
no it gets its full title like it's
khaleesi every single time it's the
declaration of independence
um so if the andals yeah they say that
about 500 times in this film
anyways uh keep going and use it to
re-steal
a bunch of treasure that america already
stole
ebler bazoonam that's american for
finders keepers
so paused i think that i was just
shocked
and baffled by this movie but in the end
makes a ton of sense
um i kept expecting
the treasure to be something like some
greater
truth like some historical artifact
maybe like a note from the founders on
like the real meaning of christmas or
like uh you know
a special thing that would bring joy and
love to america but it literally is just
a pile of stolen treasure of treasure
you know that that is what homer finds
when he finally unearths lincoln's goal
is a note from lincoln about the soul of
america
exactly so i i just did it better if
they did do it better
i kept waiting for that reveal of like
the founding fathers
you know being the type of men that they
were at least in legend
um uh would leave something more
meaningful
and more spiritual behind but it really
is just a cave full of gold
yeah now we really live in a much more
cynical time than when this movie was
made like today if you made a movie
about hunting the illuminati's like
treasure room
yeah they'd be given some kind of nobler
purpose it's like we have to find this
to like give all these treasures back to
the countries they were stolen from or
like
we need the money for this noble good
thing and it's like this one is just
like nope
the illuminati and we want the treasure
and uh harvey keitel's part of the
secret society so he's on board
very non-cynical view of like the elite
masters who founded america and then
like kept all of its riches for
themselves
the end yeah then they all buy mansions
and drive off in sports
that's america baby yeah all right
anyways
keep going i just i my jaw dropped when
it was a literal room of treasure
i think uh one of the one of the stars i
wrote that didn't that didn't get it was
like
you get that shot of the archive and
it's like it's the end of raiders it's
like we have top men looking at it
but just gold like endless gold as far
as you can see
and that's like the end that's the happy
ending got it we got the gold
okay keep going for finders keepers
meet benjamin franklin gates the least
subtle name for the most subtle nic cage
character
who's basically ross geller if he were a
professional american knower
but who solves puzzles like he's the
world's greatest detective
adam west's batman the legend uh bravo
for this comparison
worked out quite well maps have legends
maps have keys
how do you make a dishonest shortcake
library clearly a corrupted version of
the word library the map said here
at the wall spelled with two e's wall
street follows the path of an actual
wall with the original dutch settlers
built as a defense the main gate was
located a street called tahir
also two weeks when is the time of the
clock like the
whistle of a train when it's two to two
dude this movie is about the freemasons
and this movie was produced by jerry
bruckheimer who also made the rock where
sean connery plays john mason
connery connory ornery
ornery con lying old people and little
person lod
general hummel who is played by ed
harris khan harris conair
which was also produced by bruckheimer
and starred nicholas cage
and the philippines um john does that
voice almost every honest trailers
recording session so we finally found a
use for it
he does enjoy the nicholas cage yeah we
finally found a place
oh yeah yeah um i got to think about
what other
voices he he really nails and then then
we'll write to that
i mean obviously he like voices optimus
prime and certain things i was going to
say transformers is almost cheating
because
he does those professionally um but
uh i'll get back to you he does a lot of
good celebrity stuff um
some that would like shock you at how
good it is but uh
yeah sometimes i'll hear him do an
impression like it's not only a good
impression but it doesn't sound like
he's producing that
sound at all like that's amazing he's
like it doesn't sound like any of his
other voices
yeah um but this this worked out perfect
so i'm glad i'm glad we found a way to
get his nic cage into the nick cage
movie
right yeah and it's like in the doing
the batman it like all
overlapped batman nicholas cage john's
impression like it all
you know layers on top of them delicious
okay keep going nicholas cage
and the villain with cyrus the virus
coronavirus
a con in the air wake up sheeple
but to pull off the heist of the
bicentennial this walking pub trivia
night is gonna need a kick-ass crew
so he's bringing along this one nerd
he knows everything i'm tracking you
through the gps and shots yeah pause
um i guess it maybe it's just like
if the script through went through
revisions or just like a just a bizarre
choice but they start
the montage that you get in every
uh um heist movie of like assembling the
crew putting the crew together putting
the plan together
but it's just this one guy it's just it
is
it's crazy that he doesn't put any kind
of
crew together like it just why wouldn't
you want more people because they don't
even plan on bringing
dianne kruger with them she's like she
comes along on her own
accident they're kind of trying to get
rid of her for a while so like
you don't want and you're going up
against a whole team of mercenaries
it's such a fun opportunity to be like
we need a driver like we need a
distraction we needed this we needed
that but it's just him and doug from the
hangover and doug from the hangover and
then it's like i guess we'll bring along
this woman who wants to have me arrested
who hates me and then let's go pick up
like my cranky father who doesn't even
believe in any of this stuff but that's
after that
she shows up at well she joins them
really after the heist is
over and then progress void comes in at
the very end basically yeah
yeah oh man we don't get a chance to
talk about jon voight in the australia
just that was an interesting choice to
portray him as a guy who doesn't believe
in conspiracy theories
playing against type there anyways look
at look into more john
about jon voight if you want that joke
explained go honestly don't look at him
yeah all right keep playing oh daylight
savings wasn't established until world
war one
how could the ship wind up weird here it
could be that the hydrothermic
properties of this region produce
hurricane force
ice storms until it's funny for him to
not know anything
it's an outdoor cipher oh okay
what's an dwarf cipher do you know what
the preservation one is for
delicious this is why it could have been
three different characters what did we
do with them
yeah and and might have been honestly in
an earlier
together they'll rope one more person
i was gonna say uh one funny thing i do
remember about the sequel
is that it opens with cage having to go
you know get riley back to come on the
next adventure
and they have this beat where like their
fun relationship from the first movie
would be like
remember that all right here's the new
beat but you realize they
don't really have a beat from the first
movie so it's just like
we're back let's let's go like it's like
you're missing that they had
nothing to the screenwriters of part two
had nothing to draw on from the first
movie of like
let's get back into their thing and had
to let's rain from scratch because
there's like
one line about like um like i
i took you off of your desk job like do
you want to go back to your desk
and it does feel like i'm sure the
original i'm sure the original draft of
national treasure
there was a fun dynamic between uh riley
and ben of course you'd write it that
way
that just got dropped you know like with
the pacing or whatever
but yeah it does sort of feel like we
don't even really get the relate is
is riley his assistant his intern his
student
his son yeah it's just like there's just
this other guy
there and we're not even sure what their
like why
he specifically is there it's just like
that's the guy who's there
yeah he's the quipster yep yeah
all right keep going together they'll
rub one more person into their skin
woman very cute man who spends the
entire movie being told to shut up now
can you please stop
shouting give me that you're still shy
quiet please
now shush she really can't shut her
mouth can't she shut up
please she's the one calling all the
shots now she won't shut up
until she rewards our hero's patriotic
tomb raiding with a map to her vagina
where does it lead to you'll figure it
out oh
the rio national treasure was inside her
all along
strap in for an action
such an innocent naive babe in the woods
that i didn't realize that she was
talking about sex
at the end i thought it was like oh it's
like a map to their new house
the huge house that's right there yeah
she drew them a map
like they were gonna play hide and seek
yeah i would i would like to see what
the
what she drew like it's not clear
what's on that paper that she handed him
i i understood what the it looks like
the washington monument
yeah going into the reflecting pool yeah
i mean is it dirty
is it like a literal map to their
bedroom like what what
what's the cute flirty thing that you
that's the movie prop i would like to
buy
at nick cage's
it's filled with clues don't put it
under a black light
all right keep playing strap in for an
action-packed mandatory high
school field trip as the movie gives our
nation's substitute teachers enough ben
franklin facts to excuse at least five
smoke breaks
do you actually know who the first
person to suggest daylight savings was
benjamin franklin and phil's in the rest
of the runtime terrible environment
shootouts and explosions
until the day is saved thanks to skills
you learned from your real history
teacher
video
[Music]
so games a movie that blows loads for
america
ruckheimer style that'll take you back
to simpler times where our only
adversaries were blonde euro honks
trying to steal our coin collections
and the secret cabal who robbed other
cultures
the european the villain in this sean
bean
first of all they're working together in
the first five minutes and in the first
30 seconds i said
i wonder if the only guy without an
american accent is gonna
turn to evil and betray them yeah and
five minutes later
yes he does but he he's incredibly well
funded he
and it like i don't get where he's
coming from so he's gonna
find the treasure and then just sell it
to like like somehow on the black market
like sell all these historical artifacts
yeah i mean right i mean i'm guessing
he's got like a hundred
fences set up around the world to start
moving all of this product or
or you know you just take a little bit
of it and leave the rest to
descendants or i don't who knows what he
gives me
they gave me heavy vibes of the of the
corporate tornado chasing team in
twister
yes it's very much like he's just in
treasure hunting for the money
a little weird but uh the other the
other thing is
and i and i get from a screenwriting
perspective like i don't know what you
would do to get around this really it's
just kind of baked in
problem but his ability to follow
nick cage so closely throughout the
movie really undermines
benjamin gates as a brilliant
singular problem solver like how how
tough could these puzzles be
bean's figuring him out right he's not
even from here he's right on your tail
like imagine if i was in london and i
was immediately like well we need to go
to this tavern where dr
johnson customer like i'm like i should
be able to keep up with a british person
it's really like i thought nicolas cage
was some sort of american history guru
savant
he'd have home field advantage and yeah
as far as his his credentials i think
they like
they just kind of dump him on you um
just to justify
any sort of action protagonist thing he
might need to do in the film they're
like
he's a phd historian navy
uh navy seal um engineer guy
right but like lean is just like putting
this all together in his head too like
wait go over there old north church
we're going into boston like how are you
doing this i thought this was
i thought this was nicholas cage's
specialty
you're not a gate sir sir you are no
gates
um you can't know our facts those are
our facts you're not allowed to know our
facts you got to know your facts dude
they're about trafalgar or something
cromwell yeah that's that's a word
yeah cockfordshire that's probably a
place it's like when i need to know
about neville chamberlain yeah
we'll call you take fancy a tube
right i'll bet you do uh cleopatra's
needle get out of here
magna cart your ass out of here all
right that is actually they have we have
one of the magna cartas in the national
archives you can see that
you can see that right next to the
declaration of independence you can
steal the magna carta
oh great um okay well
i will not be checking that out let's
keep going there's a bunch of them they
made a bunch of copies it's not it's not
that cool
trying to steal our coin collections and
the secret cabal who robbed other
cultures
ran the country in secret and hold the
highest positions in law enforcement
was like a super cool good thing that
any kid would be happy to join
do you so swear so swear
oh i want to be in the deep state
starring
in the alex jones the da vinci chode
doctor girlfriend surprise motherfu
one does not simply walk into the
national archives the wolf
historians being reckless with priceless
artifacts
don't break it
[Music]
yeah a lot of that
i found the charlotte you mean she was a
ship yeah she was beautiful
[Music]
sassy black glary
specialty
do you want something shut up
and the only time nick cage gets to nick
cage no there are no more clues
that's it okay it's over red white
paws i mean we didn't really talk about
it but they've got the
they've got the restraints on nick cage
in this uh in this film
i mean i think this is one of those
those times where
like sometimes you could tell that that
the director is like pulling him aside
and he's like
we're we're at a 12. you like go give
giving like john woo was like give me
all you got just like
lay it on me and then i yeah i feel like
other times the conversation is like
we're gonna let the material kind of
lead like
he's always in control it's not like
he's just
doing nick cage in every movie it's like
sometimes the situation calls for
big nicholas cage and sometimes he calls
for regular nicholas at the end of the
day this is a disney movie you know
they're not gonna let him
scare the children right i mean i think
in this case it's like well he's the
he's the you know he's the straight man
he's our vehicle into the story so he
can't be
honeymoon and vegasing all over the
place because that would throw us off
you know
yeah i would like to point out uh casey
supersonic in the in the chat makes an
excellent point uh
uh it's not that sean bean is solving
all of the puzzles himself
he's using the internet so of course
that doesn't undermine nicholas cage at
all how could the founding fathers have
foreseen the internet
yahoo yeah whatever they were using in
in uh imagine
98. yeah imagine them writing these
puzzles and then finding out we were
just going to cheat with like a
system that knows everything it's like
they didn't know about posted stowe
themselves
stinky bastards witchcraft um
all right let's wrap this up yeah okay
it's over
red white and blues clues
how do a bunch of guys with hand tools
build all this same way i built the
pyramids
the great wall of china slaves
yeah no mention of uh the old slavery in
this uh this year america 11 film
yeah well i mean that's what i mean like
i think if you made this today you'd
have to be a little bit more cynical
about like the founding father it's the
underground railroad there would be a
chase
it'd be a literal railroad that he would
be yeah
on a car chase on yeah if there's
there's just no way it would be so
uncynical about like all of the founding
fathers being like heroes
and you know amazing and whatever yeah
you know you'd have to cut it in
somewhere
yeah well uh we got some outtakes for
you but first
uh well we have you break us off a
little like and subscribe you know
um it's like uh voting but on youtube
for things you like i don't know that's
a tortured comparison go actually vote
but also
police voting and then
us the like and the subscribe and ring
that liberty bell so that we can uh
notify every time we do another one yeah
it's like it's like voting but you're
not at risk of losing your cherished
freedoms
yes or are you um
we cut some stuff out of this trailer
let's see what that was
story dummy ocean that one not famous
guy from the hangover
the paper chase american her story sex
we being new surprisingly didn't die
voigt international tough daddy and
mason
damn it benjamin i'm a professor not a
professional film and television actor
american crime story america the booty
fool
raiders of the lost archive antiques
explode show
american psychos national embarrassment
a lot of titles
still better than hamilton oh that was
mine
and if anyone should come out without me
well use your imagination one generally
doesn't go into gooning if one wishes to
use their imagination
yeah don't tell your goons to use their
imagination
that's what you get into the good game
for um
let's see i did like antiques explode
show that was one of mine i
that that what i thought sometimes you
write it and you're like that's gonna
get through
i really thought i believed in that one
yeah redwood and blue's clue is very
funny
all of um all the questions i'm seeing
are nic cage
related so are you ready to do a little
little rage in the cage sure
um nick cage is very tame in this which
performance
is the best crazy one ah i have a lot of
thoughts on this i mean i mentioned
honeymoon in vegas which i think is one
of his underappreciated
go bananas over the top i mean obviously
i think you have to talk about
face off caster troy maybe a definitive
crazy bonkers nicholas cage roll and i
will say i've interviewed him and asked
him this specific question
what's his favorite big operatic
nicholas cage performance he said ghost
rider spirit of vengeance
um specifically performed for me the
moment where he goes
he's scratching at the door he's
scratching at the door
and that was the one in i think it was a
gq or an esquire interview where he
talked about how he had
sewn certain like voodoo artifacts into
his costumes
that you know only he would know were
there to influence his performance
so that one that one's definitely worth
a look uh
mandy i think oh yeah love mandy yeah
uh also that clip of oh i mean conair we
haven't mentioned conair maybe the
greatest
accent of yes of his career yeah uh
and then there's oh go ahead it is that
moment in face off where he's
sean archer as caster troy in the prison
in the prison fight where he gets
punched in the face and then like you
see
every possible human expression come
across his face
a whole bit from face-off where he's the
in the priest costume when he still
destroyers himself and he's putting the
bomb in the church and he's dancing
around and grabbing the women as the
priest
i'm sorry a lot it's the la convention
center that for some reason has
an entire church service going on in its
uh because
just because you know i guess it's yeah
god con that weekend
yeah um all that stuff uh uh amazing
and also that clip from the 80s talk
show appearance where he like
somersaults out on stage that just
starts throwing money at the cameraman
have you ever seen this i have not seen
that
i'll post it to twitter after this so if
you follow me on twitter you can see it
i will send it to you as well it's
it's a it's a good he's you know on
something or drunk or whatever and he
comes out it's like this local tv show
and he's just
like a lunatic it's the most cagey clip
i can think of
uh zachary delia asks do you think a
crossover between men in black
and national treasure would work or
would it be self-contradictory
i think you could do a whole ancient
aliens uh tie-in thing i mean
yeah it would lose some of its reverence
for um
you know east coast americana but i
think that
to combine that with aliens would be a
lot of fun you'd have to semi retcon i
believe the first men in black implies
that that the men in black
organization was formed after roswell
so you'd have to retcon that that like
there were earlier incarnations of
men in black or some other agency that
was around in the early days of america
doing their same
kind of work but that's doable i think
so like all you'd need to do is that and
then
your boom you're all set up yeah um
let's see and i guess
finally um what movie would be better
if you recast the lead with nick cage i
mean
that's yeah but what wouldn't be i think
like uh
for me i'm gonna pick manchester by the
sea yeah i think that uh
casey affleck had a real restrained take
on uh
on depression and and grief and um i'd
like to see
uh the same film with with different
acting choices made
i would love to see uh a christmas carol
with cage as scrooge
like i feel like scrooge would be fun
but even like a more
serious take uh i'd like to see cage be
visited by three holiday spirits
yeah and the truth is like i know it's a
silly question but like
he can act like he has amazing range and
he can be subtle and he can be subdued
and he can
um be genuine and and not over the top
and
have some realism in his performances he
just chooses not to
um for a lot of the time or in this
stage in his career
there is also a question in the chat of
what is the best restrained or
tame nicholas cage performance and i'm
gonna go ahead and say uh david gordon
green's joe
from 2013. i never saw that
uh very subtle but great a really like
one of those movies that really reminds
you
oh right nicholas cage like a real actor
and he's he's fitting what he does
to the movie he's not just out there
being crazy and everything
yeah i mean moonstruck uh he won oscar
for right
um leaving las vegas leaving las vegas
excuse me
um uh nominated for moonstruck i believe
yeah um adaptation's fantastic uh
yeah yeah he's a lot of movies he's
great he's great in some of these movies
where he's over the top like i think
like honeymoon in vegas is a
legitimately good performance
like that's a big wacky comedy he's
supposed to be
you know big it's not all cage
but it's an interesting like late career
uh
move because i feel like i wish a lot of
stars would have
tried that and i guess they have in a
sense but like they become the most
distilled
intense version of themselves possible
like right like they sort of
shut the risk of becoming caricatures of
themselves
nicholson right this is like always what
kind of happens with those
iconic guys at a certain point they just
start playing riffs on their persona
yeah yeah but for whatever reason i
think he keeps pushing that to like new
and more
uh bizarre heights and yeah well we're
gonna get the the unbearable weight of
massive talent next year with him and
pedro pascal if you're yeah
that seems to be where it might meet its
meta apex like where can you go from
him playing himself who's gets hired to
recreate his most beloved roles
yeah the the cage will collapse in on
itself yeah
at some point but until then we're
enjoying the ride and i hope you guys
enjoyed the ride today lon thank you for
joining me
my brother in arms my compatriot uh
and all you uh in the u.s get out there
to the polls if you haven't yet uh
if you're watching this in line stay in
line until you voted and um
other things people who know more about
civics should tell you
yeah answer that here thank you for
watching
we will see you guys tomorrow for sju oh
and next week
next week hmm uh
let's see uh next week is gonna have a
little sugar in it i'll give you that
um so we'll see you then for another
episode of honest trailers commentary
bye-bye
[Music]
you